الشرطه الامريكيه القبض على امراه من
جورجيا على خلفيه حادثه الطعن المميته
للمبتعثه السعودي الوليد الغريبي وقالت
شرطه مدينه
كول ماري روجرزالبالغ من العمر 19 عاما من
كولومبوس بولايه جورجيا محتجزه الان لديهم
ووجهت اليها تهمه القتل العمد والسرقه
والسطو وجرائم اخرى ذات السيله
يوم الاثنين الماضي كان هذا المنزل مسرحا
لعمليه قتل رحب ضحيتها طالب السعودي وليد
الغريبي ال 25 عاما قتلته نيكول ميري
الامريكيه هذه 19 عاما تفاصيل الحادث
ترويها لنا صاحبه المنزل التي وجدت وليد
غارقا في دمائه في الطابق الثالث تحديدا
في الحمام صاحبه المنزل ثم استدعائها على
العشاء من قبل القاتلين الاخرين للمنزل
قالوا لها بانهم يسمعون صوت لبدات مخنوقه
لا يعرفون مصدرها وصلت صاحبه المنزل على
عجل وجدت نيكول ميري تنظف بطريقه غريبه
تشاجرت هي واياها وعلى الفاور لكل ميري
تركت المنزل
دخلت الى سيارتها واقلعت
هنا صاحبه المنزل
حاولت ان تطلع على ماذا لا يحصل تحديدا في
الطابق الثالث وجدت باب الحمام مقفولا
حاولت بكل الطرق ان تفتحه وفي النهايه
نجحت
لتجديد غارقا في دماؤه في هذا الحمام
يصارع ويلفض نفس انفاسه الاخيره حاولت
الاتصال بالشرطه وبعد 10 دقائق تحديدا
وصلت الشرطه لتعلن وفاه وليد عند الساعه
11:00
صباحا 51 دقيقه
ومعنى من الرياض سلطان الغريبي عامه
المبتعث المقتول في بنسلفانيا سيد سلطان
عظم الله اجركم اولا يعني حادثه مروعه
مفجعه بصراحه كل وسائل الاعلام يعني
الدوليه تناقلت هذه القصه لكن اريد
الروايه من
اهل الوليد ما الذي وصلكم كيف استقبلتم
ايضا او نقل لكم هذا الخبر
والله يغفر له ويرحمه همم الخبر جاء
تقريبا يوم الاثنين الساعه
[موسيقى]
12:00 بالليل
يا ايميل من شرطه بلد فيها على
[موسيقى]
ايميل
ابوها الساعه 12
طالبين بهم
عليه التواصل معهم بشان
قضيه تخص الوليد في قسم القتل
بصراحه الاميركان مربك شوي لانه ما كان في
تفاصيل ولكن
[موسيقى]
مقتول يعني
تواصل معهم اتصل عليهم
فاعطوه بعض المعلومات انه ااه
الوليد تعرض همم اعتذار ومن همم
فتاه همم بدون تفاصيل وين كان انه تعرض
همم
ادى الى مقتله تعال
امم كده بالالوان
الدكتور عبد الله على
السفاره
واعطاهم بعض المعلومات في نفس الوقت كانت
الشرطه
تواصلت مع السفاره
في نفس اليوم همم يعني تقريبا بالنسبه
لتوقيت الولايات المتحده اشتغلت السفاره
فريق الى همم
[موسيقى]
التحقيق واا كمال اجراءات القضيه فيها
طيب السؤال افضل
طبعا
الان موجود
فيها ورجع الى واشنطن بعد بعد ما انتهت
الاجراءات هناك
في الاجراءات يعني او من التطورات او من
تفاصيل ايضا ايش الدوافع ايضا دوافع هذا
القتل اللي يطلعوها همم يعني او شافها
الولد المقتول الدكتور عبد الله
نعم وكانت
القضيه هم الفتاه كانت ساكنه معه في نفس
البنايه وفي نفس الشيه لان الشله عباره عن
مجموعه غرف
لكل ساكن الغرفه
وفي الخدمات مشتركه مثل دورات المياه
والمطبخ وصلاه الجلوس هذه المشتركه بين
همم السكان وهي كان هو ساكن الدور الثاني
وهي في الدور الثالث
من اسبوع او اكثر
يعني مش الاسباب يعني ليش يعني كانت
مترصده لقتله منذ اسبوع
يعني محتويات
بهذا الشال يعني وحسب ما يعني صدر انه
كانت همم
الغرفه لمده همم 18 يوم
طبعا هي خرج خرجت قبل ما تنتهي هذه المده
اللي مستغيراتها في اليوم اللي كانت تبي
تخرج فيه اللي هو يوم الاثنين الماضي على
الساعه
11:11 ونصف تقريبا نزلت
[موسيقى]
الوليد في غرفه وطلبت منه
يساعدها في حمل بعض الاغراض
همم يعني طلع بحس انه
لما طلع
من هي كانت طبعا
مستعده من النظام بادوات
نعم جريمه
حاول القهوه
[موسيقى]
واعطته همم
بعدين دخلتوا للحمام
فاجهزت عليه تماما يعني في عدد من
الطاعهانات في اماكن همم متعدده من جسمك
فقال يعني اغلقت همم
الحمام بالمفتاح
ثم نزلت همم
غرفه همم الوليد رحمه الله عليه
فاستولد على
اغراضه مثل همم
الموبايل همم المفاتيح
اشياء كثيره
عن الوليد يعني هو منذ متى موجود في
الولايات المتحده ومبتعث يدرس وكان يعني
يدرس رحمه الله عليه البكالوريس
منذ سنوات
الدكتور عبد الله في الملحقيه الثقافيه في
واشنط
[موسيقى]
نفس المرحله الثانويه بعد ما انتهت
المرحله دراسته في المرحله الثانويه
انتحرت
طيب فتره انتهى عمل والد والرجعه هو باقي
هناك
واكل دراسته وكان على وشك التخرج يمكن كان
متبقي له همم من شهرين الى ثلاث شهور
وبعد ذلك ارجع الى السعوديه مره اخرى الى
اهله
اي نعم خلاص التخرجه بيرجع هنا
ومتى ستصل كيف تتم ترتيبات نقل الجثه الى
السعوديه ان كانت ستنقل
هي كل الاجراءات تقريبا انتهت من
الشرطه من السفاره نقي فقط شهاده الوفاه
ان شاء الله يعني همم اليوم همم تصلهم
وبكم هذا اليوم وهو اخر يوم عمل في
الولايات المتحده همم ان شاء الله تكون
وصلاتهم اليوم اذا وصلتهم اليوم باذن الله
همم بكره او بعد بكره يكون وصل باذن الله
رحمه الله عليه رحمه الله عليه تعز الحاره
مره اخرى الله يعظم اجركم ويرحم تقول لكم
شكرا جزيلا لك من الرياض سلطان الغريب يا
عم المبتعث المقتول في بنسلفانيا الوليد
الغريب شكرا جزيلا